what is happening there citizens of the
reject Nation Michael and I are back to
watch the bad batch and now my audio
sounds better I will not redo this intro
it's raw real reactions uh guys it's the
real in real rejects real rejects follow
this guy multi-house dot i o where they
are changing the game all things Cinema
wise we are a la based production
company we've worked with this amazing
guy put him in one of her things he did
okay and by okay I mean it was an
award-winning film thanks to you thanks
to me I want all of you it was just you
it was just Greg and that no leave a
like on this video use a force leave a
like uh full-length watch Longs recently
with your own copy of the bad batch
available for a super sexy Rejects at
our patreon page that's what we call our
patrons to make them feel more special I
think it works and yeah let's get to it
[Music]
where's my title
tribe tribe interesting
oh I like that we'll make the delivery
Echo Omega got the ship
I hate God in the ship I just want to
find some treasure
kill some Power Rangers Vines
[Music]
what's going down oh
your Assurance is meaningless check each
one A lot's changed since the Clone days
how dare you salt text intelligence
we saw these chain codes and Rebels call
out an Easter egg people
I don't like it
no me neither it's like you have a
bad feeling about it
I feel like she's gonna pick up a broom
with the force
[Laughter]
like one shot for five seconds
oh
it's gungy
do not interfere with Vanguard access
business
ah yeah buddy
that is kanji more coming they said yeah
a little grown up
[Music]
why do they have him here
well you know we'll find out Wookies
tend to be turned into slaves in the
Imperial era that's the first thing they
did in kashyyk
[Music]
oh this is an exciting episode yeah
right I'm liking it so far
[Music]
nicely done my friend oh gungy
come on let's go
finding your lightsaber find your
lightsaber you need to go before they
find you Omega
get back to the ship
oh
[Music]
he's traumatized man
destroys are after him come on
[Music]
that's a nice nice detail it has a very
nice detail yeah it was like Kanan and
Rebels
what sort of treachery is
oh you know I would advise you to take
your soldiers and extricate yourselves
from a situation The Wookie is worth a
great deal to our buyer
ah you can't smuggle living beings for
the right price the lightsaber yeah
oh it's the first time she's witnessing
this oh the force oh [__] let's go let's
go
oh yeah
[Music]
oh there's something really nostalgic in
a weird way of her him and Omega being
paired up together all right just two
younglings take a leap of faith man ah
[Music]
I wonder if the buyer is the Empire
or if it's slave Traders why is he
sitting back there alone
you wouldn't get it Omega
crunchy
here you look hungry
hungry kanji oh a little Bento Box
what's wrong he doesn't trust us how all
clones were given in order to execute
the Jedi he has good reason to be
cautious exactly
we did not follow that order you don't
have to be afraid of us
it's okay eat
I'm Omega what's your name
my work is a little rusty but translate
says his name is gunchy that's it's not
bad it was attempting to reach the
Wookie Homeworld of kashyyk before he
was captured by those smuggling droids
I'm not sure how you survived this long
on your own these Jedi it's impressive
still a Padawan if that I know okay it's
been a while since we've been to kashyyk
oh keshik's not going to be great the
Empire could have outposts there by now
he's he's a Jedi he's not safe anywhere
that is true maybe they'll run into a
sag Herrera and Cal castis were there
or you know like tarful or chewy or any
of the wookies don't care about them
this baby
be able to help you no they're going to
be enslaved but I'm picking up heavy
smoke deforestation an eye out for
Imperial outposts
oh kid keep that laser sword hidden
oh is your sword attention we don't want
come on
you know what it's called
that was just offensive
[Music]
uh tribe I get it now I get it oh I hope
they come in on like the holiday special
yes yeah we see all Chewie's family
oh he looks so happy oh it's about to
have his heart broken
what about this planet
he was so young
bugs
[Music]
they're swarming us
no no no
he says they will not attack unless we
pose a threat
[Music]
a lot of Jedis can commune can't you
should just join the team forget kushik
yeah there's not gonna be a lot left
[Applause]
sound like attacker attack of the Clones
genosis Arena it's called an Easter egg
people
[Music]
I'm Jewish we don't have Easter
oh man
what if he does join the team that would
be cool I feel like that would be a nice
addition yeah
certainly puts a Target on their back
wasn't already a big one
centered at the entire Village
no
oh poor guy our home too
don't worry we'll find your people
oh maybe some of them are still there
being enslaved or something
I mean that's where we meet Chewie and
solo
[Music]
I just feel so sorry
on that
you mess with the wrong wookie
[Music]
ice
no oh you're happiest there's no
expression and I love them
yeah I really want country in the bad
batch look how cool it is with them two
together I love them together man
[Music]
foreign
ocean punch
it's just that one working
I need to stop the Flames from spreading
it's pretty cool that the batch is here
just doing and ignition out of the
kindness of their hearts
like they went right into battle to save
him you know yeah
[Music]
didn't help that Genji just ran right
into them
[Music]
Vader
oh
[Music]
I want one of those
oh man oh look at that bow Caster hmm
hell yeah oh it's time to wreak havoc
oh look there's still some people man
guerrilla warfare with the wookies
[Music]
who came because Genji was in trouble
these still a child
he needs his people
this is great they're really resolving
like all the gunji story and it's nice
because Wookies live a long time so even
if kanji stays maybe we'll uh we'll see
him again we need to notify Imperial
command not if I find the Jedi first
Sid
good soup
no thanks you don't know what you're
missing
wow
we'll stay and help you fight them
[Music]
wow this is like a very classic Star
Wars type episode
oh yeah I guess I know yeah it's like me
at church I don't know what to do
he they believe this planet belongs to
the trees
and they are allies in this fight take
all the hours we can get it's The Lorax
yeah yeah
omega's like they're tree-hugging freaks
[Music]
the Grand Ocean Convoy is closing in you
could tell by the big fire in the middle
of the night
the trees have a plan
all right
whatever they say Evil Dead style let's
go
I hope there's some tracks are broken
off
turn of the Jedi
Ewok references here
nice
[Music]
trophy was this the tree's plan
oh my God here we go
[Music]
oh man that was fast
it's great
that's a cool shot Alden literally
straight from the Patriot yeah that's
exactly what he does
scum
got a blast
[Music]
ouch
it's amazing Genji hasn't got caught
without liberally uses that lightsaber
[Music]
cool
flamethrows are like particularly rude
to Wookies
giant acorns
Maybe
nope never mind way better
[Laughter]
sacrifice some of these bugs
God it's so annoying because it's just
burnt the Earth their planet is so
frustrated
oh my God what an [__]
yeah what in the Vietnam is this
ah cool
I'm gonna pull out the whip all right
the hand oh no
[Music]
[Laughter]
he's ours
oh God
that is cruel even he's like oh man
that's a lot more harsh than I was
expecting
fire it's spreading too fast dick gather
all the wookies
problem solved
nice sleep nicely done there buddy
he found his truck
can you smoke any of these plants
foreign
[Music]
still a better plot than Avatar
no need a slight Master Cameron ah
well
that was that was great that was a great
episode that was phenomenal it was
really wonderful to see old gungy back
that was such a that was such a great uh
I'm so glad I was very worried when we
saw gungy in the trailer worried worried
[Music]
I'm trying to make it work
yeah I'll let you speak don't Kash Chic
your check just yet
okay anyway uh I really loved uh
uh no I really love that
I thought they were gonna have to kill
gunji keep them around a bit longer and
then kill him off
um and I love that in this episode I
didn't think it necessarily this episode
I thought that it may be a few episodes
with gunji as part of the bad batch and
then let's tilt this up attack oh you
got it
um crispy oh crisp uh yeah I I thought
uh I thought gunji would maybe be around
for two or three episodes
they would end up wherever they're going
to end up and then they'd get killed in
the process and they learned that
teaming up with Jedi is probably not a
good idea I thought that ganji would
become part of the dark side
there was a couple moments there when
when the trend ocean was getting by the
spider thing it's very eloquent uh or
I'm a Star Wars guy it's called spider
things
all creatures spiders yeah I mean it was
cool I mean I love seeing the the
repurposed uh tanks you know Clone Wars
era just kind of like a little battered
um I love the idea that the Surplus is
like going to be used to the you know
the slave trade and
um I mean I don't love that they're
doing that I love it
but uh you know but it's it's cool uh I
was kind of secretly hoping that we'd
see tarful
um it was just like one of my favorite
Wookies and I promise you Star Wars fans
Center satisfied but it's it's like more
cameos I know and it's a fake story no
it was very powerful for gunji to have
their their time in the sun
um you know I'm I'm kind of curious I'd
love to know where were they during
Order 66 gungy yeah like the other
younglings
uh uh I mean we do a lot of Star Wars
stories about like that I mean it's kind
of like calculus yeah I'm I'd play it
and I play that game Caleb a lot less
dialogue the after we're interested
um but no I think it's cool and I like
that they've set Kenji up where you know
we might see uh slight teenager gunji
and Ahsoka mayhaps
um with that being sense of the timeline
I thought I'd gotten ganji's a Wookie
they age very slowly
that would be like after way after
Return of the Jedi and [__] yeah guns
you'd probably be you'd probably look
like a teenager at that point in Wookie
years okay
um yeah which is which is great um I
mean something I've I've always kind of
wanted like obviously uh like by Return
of the Jedi you need to think that it's
really just Luke left and now we know
ahsoka's still there and there are some
other scattered Jedi I do love this idea
that Jedi like gungy uh might have been
completely kind of Forgotten
um but who knows maybe maybe they were
working at Luke Skywalker's Jedi Temple
um and as a slave well I was gonna say
maybe kylo Ren looks like I'm the good
slavo
yeah
um you know but uh yeah what do you
think Greg what what was your reaction
to this episode my reaction I think
spoke volumes during the actual reaction
of the episode
uh yeah no it was it was a really good
one I found it a nostalgic thing with to
have him paired up with Omega and it's
interesting what they're doing with
Omega because she is such a heart of
this and I love how they follow her
heart yeah you know whereas before they
kind of Reign in Omega and they seem
like they're like we can't Reign that
woman and she's out of control she's a
kid who's controlling our lives and
everywhere we travel and now they just
follow wherever wherever her heart
desires now whether it's treasure or
saving this random Wookie we're gonna do
it we're gonna fight with them but also
you know the the bad batch being
um they they acknowledge the history
with the wookies in this episode alone
you know saying that were the the mem
the wookies were some of her greatest
allies so we should stand by them in
this in this fight that's happening and
they're they're still representing the
good side of what it was when the Clones
were good you know yeah so I loved
having that in there and
um just the idea that you get this
resolved with gunji that they they've
been doing that once in a while here in
bad batch and that's how they brought
back in uh CAD Bane in the in the last
season and then
he had a story wonderfully concluded
and so to get gunji back here and I I do
a pretty whatever little quick CarX I
make you know the especially with the
the Tree of Life how trees have life
like if you if you look at like the DNA
on them on a molecular level of a tree
there's so many strands that are very
similar to that of a human DNA because
at the end of the day we're all made up
of the same stuff so star stuff hashtag
carbon based life forms yeah so it's
nice to have that connective tissue and
thread for a show about galaxies and
whatever when you get to the angle of
of um of being in tune with like hey
just because they're not moving their
Mouse up and down does not mean that
this thing is not it's not life doesn't
mean it doesn't communicate so you know
even Omega getting in tune with that I
thought she had a little bit more she
hasn't seen anything am I am I
remembering that incorrectly is there
something in season one where she
interact with the Jedi or something I
mean because I thought she might be like
whoa look at him moving [__] with his
mind you know it stands to reason that
given where Omega is from that there was
probably at some kind of exposure sure
to Jedi
um you know especially if they were
still doing the tours and stuff on
Camino I'm sure Jedi would come in and
out perform an act yeah uh but you know
I I think
I I completely agree with you and it was
actually a nice uh I mean Genji's
lightsaber was one of my favorite uh
parts of Clone Wars you know when uh he
was on illum with the other younglings
and this idea of creating a lightsaber
that represents who you are and and
what's part of you and uh you know so so
that was definitely uh
I love that uh yeah
uh you know and I think
it's fun to see
uh like how did a like a a youngling
Padawan managed to escape order 66. and
this is the one thing that I found a
little unbelievable is like Genji was
like lightsaber trigger happy
um to the point where like all it takes
is just seeing the marks and like you
know now the whatever wherever the
inquisitors are at um maybe he was
blending in with a tree
all the trees on course
I mean you just gotta like they must
have been somewhere they definitely
weren't into that Temple uh that's for
sure
um but then again like when I see a
Wookie I don't think Jedi is the first
thing that comes to mind I mean like and
please correct me if I'm wrong in the
comments but like pretty sure part of
the conversation with with gunji was uh
when they were on The Crucible was that
uh
there have been other Wookie Jedi but
there aren't a lot of them
um and because of that you can probably
feel a bit you know pun intended
alienated uh uh
you know so
yeah yeah and I completely agree seeing
Omega and
um and Genji together like
it was nice to to see almost two
younglings
um I can't help but Shake there's
something Force sensitive about Omega
though you are the only one who thinks
that that's I just I don't know what it
like what if that's their bad batch
thing only one who thinks that no one
else has completely completely original
Theory completely original came from my
head
um yeah uh so we'll we'll see but this
this was a nice episode and I think it
was it was also probably really good for
the batch to get a taste of being
part of something good again
getting to fight in a you know for a
cause that's it's the thing that Echo
has been a surprise Echo didn't speak up
more in this episode especially that was
the one line that that Echo did have was
about you know these were our closest
allies in the I'm just what I mean by
that is I want more of a bit a bit more
of an emotional thrust from Echo because
he had such a debate in the first
episode of this season first or second
one of the two is one episode all right
that's the first two or one episode
um so uh he had such a such a motive you
know uh and and I want to I want to just
hone in a little bit more you know kind
of uh
kind of spread that out let it let it
Blossom a little bit more about like we
should fight because of this there
hasn't been as much conflict in that
regard as I would have liked um but
we're also still so early in the season
I know it's like 58 episodes per season
every time we talk about it it goes up
20 more episodes they're producing them
as they release
yeah I do love that um
there's just continued payoffs for fans
of Clone Wars
um and I think that's what bad batch is
I mean it's a love letter to fans of the
Clone Wars oh totally
um that's why I pained me that we didn't
have John join us for this reaction
because he he's seen all the clothes all
those who keep asking I uh I just wanted
to Rob him of the experience
I I've been re-watching season one of
Clone Wars and uh I started with the
original animated movie oh man I saw
that in theaters I forgot how amazing it
is
there's nothing better than a little
baby Hut
um
no and you're thinking of the original
movie
I'm thinking of the original original
Clone Wars oh like a like attacking the
Clones no remember there's the am I
thinking of the right one are you
thinking of the micro series yes the the
on the from Cartoon Network yeah
you watch your mouth great terrible the
worst one are you kidding I mean that's
made by the guy that did Samurai Jack
also Empire Strikes Back is overrated oh
my God all right okay Last Jedi uh
that's the best one in the world
and it rises Skywalker is
underappreciated
attack of the Clones is the best I just
honestly the I would have been fine I
wanted another solo movie
Amelia Clark oh man
um well on that note uh I think we just
lost all of our Star Wars fans for no
man I was just giving honest opinions
yeah I call them hot takes hot buttons I
just
the one thing about the sequel Trilogy
that I can't handle it's not how
Palpatine just magically returns it's
not the lack of
Storytelling it's none of it's none of
that Greg the thing that bothers me
is that
ghost Yoda isn't transparent enough like
they just needed to lower the opacity by
like 20 bothers me that kylo and uh Ray
didn't use any tongue
they did
they did Last Jedi extended edition
[Laughter]
it's a weird expectations uh why do why
did we get the yellow lightsaber at the
very end that's my question okay that's
why we have to wait for that because
yellow is a color that blends both
colors of green and red
trust me I don't art trust me that's how
it works yeah it represents the gray I I
want to pick up
old lady
Omega gun G
and
I don't know Ezra Richard I don't just
make it a Motley Crew and I want them to
on Tatooine
be on a treasure hunt true with Hondo
and I want them to find Luke and Leia's
lightsabers
uh and also uh the bugs were cool I even
like how they gave the bugs you know
they they introduce I like anything that
deals with a gray quality you know when
the bugs first show up you're like ah
scary and then not chewy ganji is like
forced and then when they come back in
later and they're like no this is our
bad guy look what he's doing boom and
they
I don't know he's gonna be what are they
going to do they're gonna lay some eggs
in them or something
yeah no that's probably exactly what
they're gonna do
um that's awesome I'd watch that spin
off I do spin because it's
a space spider anyway uh no I I love
that too and I thought it was Phantom
Menace it was the best uh
in the visual effects Department I agree
yeah I agree
yeah
anyway uh
I can't even do my my lips that way uh
so slimo
oh man uh if you're not subscribed
or something do that please
um you're making too many good points I
gotta interrupt it and upset people I
wish Craig could just be sincere Now
Greg is so sincere and Greg knows so
much about Star Wars I know just enough
to pass a video that's we definitely
don't have Wikipedia on the screen at
all yeah let me just close out like
several browsers right now
yeah it's um
this was a fun
reminder that Jedi still exist I hope
that we see more Jedi
um
I hope that we see more Jedi uh and I
hope that they kill some of them off
because the one thing that they haven't
done enough of is killing off Jedi post
order 66. in my humble opinion
feel
I feel like I want to see more dead Jedi
this is what we do when we're waiting
for something else to drop and we just
overly talk about an episode that we
were done talking about I wasn't done
talking about seven minutes I still I
still have thoughts oh I was gonna say
gungy
and Ezra Bridger I like that both of
them are are Jedi that have a particular
Affinity with living creatures
um yeah it's like one of those things
that like sexual
um it could be but Jedi were not allowed
to have those kind of feelings
or they're not allowed to act out shut
up what what why would no wonder that
someone go to the dark side oh if you
think about it from a practical
standpoint like yeah I'd be on the dark
side of note yeah screw this like Count
Dooku just wanted a girlfriend
[Laughter]
but he couldn't find any because his
lightsaber bends to the right a little
bit oh
Palpatine returned to get laid
is that uh Canon yeah it's Canon GJ
rooms that's Canon
um yeah you ever you ever wonder you
know let's like go back in time you know
Disney just bought Star Wars really
exciting they bring in some of the best
creative minds of our time into a room
you have legendary producer Kathleen
Kennedy
legendary director JJ Abrams they have
all these Brilliant Minds hell you bring
back some of the original writers
Lawrence Caston uh
and then they don't make a plan
yeah it just it keeps me up at night
Greg
gives me up at night and I like to think
that
Dave filoni
has a play as a plan he has a plan It's
a grand plan and we're all part of it
you just need to accept Dave filoni as
your personal Lord and Savior and the
moment you do the moment your life will
be happy
I'm right there with you Michael yeah
I'm ready to move on now you ready to
move on all right well
do people have to pay extra money to
watch this whole version we're done
we're done everyone uh let me know what
it's like to live a better life and uh
subscribe click that Bell and this was a
good episode I enjoyed this one quite a
bit
fellow Michael
multihouse.io it's a china-based company
it's a china-based company that is all
about converting people to Dave filonism
talking to guys soon
[Music]